es sind mächtige Bilder die teils
einflussreiche Netzwerke für sich nutzen
wollen der rechtsextreme dritte Weg ruft
online zu Protesten auf auch die freien
Sachsen wenden sich bei telegram an
150.000 Abonnenten das Kalkül es soll so
aussehen als ob sie die bauernproteste
Steuern würden und die Politik steigt
auf dieses narrativ voll
einkussieren Aufrufe mit
umsturzfantasien extremistische Gruppen
formieren sich tölkisch nationalistische
Symbole werden offen gezeigt den geht's
nicht um die deutsche Landwirtschaft die
haben feuchte Träume von Umstürzen auch
Innenministerin fäer warnte vor
Rechtsextremisten und demokratiefeinden
die die Proteste Karpern und
instrumentalisieren wollen solche
Aussagen provozieren Reaktionen in den
sozialen Netzwerken Zustimmung
Widerspruch egal Hauptsache über das
Thema wird geredet dadurch wird deren
Einfluss größer dargestellt als er in
Wahrheit ist Berlin direkt hat in allen
16 Bundes Ländern nachgefragt
rechtsextreme gibt es zwar vereinzelt in
der Protestbewegung doch auf den Straßen
spielen sie faktisch keine Rolle keine
Straftaten weitestgehend friedlich keine
Unterwanderung durch
Rechtsextremisten durch solche Worte wie
Allmachtsfantasien Umsturzpläne oder
umsturzfantasien wie habeg das gemacht
hat das ist wirklich bösartig und das
war auch gezielt so man wollte diese
Proteste diskreditieren von vorne rein
und die Bevölkerung und die Landwirte
ten das ist misslungen und das ist gut
so Innenministerin fäer hält ihre
frühzeitige Warnung trotzdem für
berechtigt in dem Rechtsstaat geht's
immer darum das Grundgesetz zu
verteidigen das ist meine Aufgabe auch
als verfassungsministerin und da muss
man rechtzeitig klare Sprache auch haben
und auch Ansagen machen so verstehe ich
auch innere Sicherheitspolitik das hat
nichts mit politisch schnellen gewinnen
zu tun um Gottes Willen gerade nicht
Finanzminister chran Lindner
widerspricht heute werden seh schell
Stimmen laut auch aus den Reihen unserer
Koalitionspartner die von einer
Radikalisierung sprechen und davor
warnen die bauernproteste verlaufen
friedlich das so viel darüber diskutiert
wird ist ein Erfolg für Rechtsextreme
Netzwerke sagen Forscher es gelang auch
schon bei anderen Themen Corona
Energiekrise Russland bei diesen Themen
suggerierten Aktivisten mehr Einfluss
als sie tatsächlich hatten relevant sind
die Versuche dennoch wie sie hier
erforscht haben das konkrete Thema eines
Protest eine Debatte ist rechtsextrem
erstmal zweitrangig es geht darum dass
bestimmte Themen als rechts wahrgenommen
werden in der Öffentlichkeit und wenn
gewisse Themen als rechts wahrgenommen
werden hat man eine gewissen Raumgewinn
in denen auch es schwieriger ist
demokratische Position dagegen zu setzen
auch junge Bauern haben das verstanden
in einem Instagram Video mit fast 5
Millionen aufrufen distanzieren sie sich
von rechts allein dass sie das machen
mussten ist ein Erfolg der
einflussreichen Netzwerke denn sie geben
den Bauern vor worüber Sie reden müssen
wir würden total gerne über Inhalte
sprechen wir würden gerne sagen was für
für Forderungen haben was wir als
junglandwirtin brauchen um in Zukunft
unseren Beruf ausüben zu können und
haben eigentlich gar keine Lust und
ständig gegen Rechts abzugrenzen es geht
darum dass wir eigentlich nach
Gemeinsamkeiten suchen und das sollten
wir auch gerade bei den aktuellen
Protesten probieren der Politik fehle es
zu oft an Gelassenheit so
konfliktforscher reflexartige Warnungen
vor Unterwanderung lenken ab vom
eigentlichen Thema und vergiften die
Debatte eine die sich klar an die Seite
der Bauern gestellt hat ist die
Ministerpräsidentin von Mecklenburg
Vorpommern Manuela Schwesig und die ist
mir jetzt live zugeschaltet aus Schwerin
schönen guten Abend guten aben Frau
benerg Frau Schwesig sie haben in einem
Interview Anfang der Woche gesagt dass
sie ihren persönlichen Draht zur
Bundesregierung auch nutzen werden um
sich für einen Erhalt der Subventionen
für die Bauern einzusetzen wenn man
jetzt Olaf Scholz in dem Video hört da
scheint nicht viel ang kommmen zu sein
was erwarten sie denn jetzt von der
Ampel noch für ein Angebot an die
Bauern ich verstehe die Proteste der
Bauern weil ich seit vielen Jahren
selbst mit dem Bauernverband in den
landwirtschaftlichen Betrieben unterwegs
bin zwei Drittel der Menschen bei uns
leben im ländlichen Raum und die Art und
Weise wie jetzt die Sparvorschläge
gemacht worden sind und wie auch der
Kompromiss zustande kam nämlich ohne
dabei die Verbände mitzunehmen die
Betroffenen mitzunehmen hat einfach das
fast zum Überlaufen gebracht und ich bin
sehr froh dass im ersten Schritt die
Bundesregierung ja nachgesteuert hat und
die kfzsteuer vom Tisch ist und jetzt im
zweiten Schritt der SPD
Fraktionsvorsitzender Rolf Mütze nicht
gesagt hat dass es nicht ein
Automatismus gibt das einfach
durchgezogen wird sondern dass man sich
jetzt an den Tisch setzt und miteinander
redet und ich habe große Erwartung in
das Gespräch morgen der
Fraktionsvorsitzende mit den Verbänden
Sowi viele weil es gut ist dass man sich
überhaupt an einen Tisch setzt und wir
als Bundesland haben ja auch
verschiedene Vorschläge gemacht wie eine
Lösung aussehen könnte sie sagen sie
verstehen die Bauern und sie setzen ihre
Hoffnung in die Fraktionsvorsitzenden
das ist aber dann immer noch nicht der
Bundeskanzler der sagt ja es sei schon
ein guter Kompromiss zu diesem
Kompromiss gehört eben die stufenweise
Abschaffung der Subventionen für
Agrardiesel damit sind die Bauern nicht
einverstanden was machen Sie wenn der
Kanzler da nicht
nachgibt es gibt ja das strukche Gesetz
dass kein Gesetz in das Parlament so
dass kein Gesetz aus dem Parlament so
rauskommt wie es reingeht der
Haushaltsgesetz ist jetzt im Parlament
und die Fraktion beraten darüber und die
Fraktionsvorsitzenden haben eben morgen
die Verbände am Tisch und ich glaube
dass es gut ist jetzt miteinander zu
reden denn es geht mittlerweile um viel
mehr als den Agrardiesel es hat einfach
das fast zum Überlaufen gebracht es geht
den Landwirten darum eine Perspektive zu
haben es geht um fare Preise es geht um
die Marktmacht der
Lebensmittelkonzerne es geht um hohe
Bodenpreise und darum wie wie kriegen
wir Klimaschutz und Tierschutz hin aber
so dass eben auch die Landwirte dabei
noch finanziell klar kommen und wir
müssen ja ein Interesse haben als Land
dass weiter bei uns regionale Produkte
produziert werden jetzt wandern viele
Produkte viele Produktion mittlerweile
ab nach Italien in andere Länder Europas
und wir müssen ja ein Interesse haben
dass bei uns die Landwirtschaft
weitergeht und das Thema ist viel größer
und deshalb ist es gut wenn morgen auch
das Thema größer beraten wird es muss um
eine Perspektive gehen und auch wenn es
größer ist entzündet sich die Wut an den
Agrardiesel an der agrardieselfrage habe
ich sie jetzt gerade richtig verstanden
dass sie im Prinzip ihre SPD Kollegen im
Bundestag dazu auffordern das Ganze noch
einmal zu kippen Rolf Mützen nicht hat
gest hat selber gesagt als SPD
Fraktionsvorsitzender dass es für sie
kein Automatismus gibt das einfach
durchgezogen wird alle Gesetze werden ja
im Parlament beraten sonst würde ja das
Parlament keinen Sinn machen und ich
hoffe sehr dass es ein Kompromiss gibt
der mit wo alle mitgehen können der
überhaupt mit den an mit den Verbänden
beraten wird und noch mal ähm was
eigentlich die Landwirte erwarten und
die Menschen im ländlichen Raum dass es
insgesamt eine Perspektive gibt es haben
sich in den letzten Jahren viele
Probleme aufgestaut ähm nicht nur erst
in der Zeit der ampelregierung im
ländlichen Raum und das muss jetzt
gelöst werden und bei der ganzen Debatte
geht's auch um eine Zukunft des
ländlichen Raums denn die Sparvorschläge
jetzt betreffen den ländlichen Raum das
ist ja auch der CO2 Preis der die
Pendler vor allem trifft das sind die
Windräder die wir Aufstellen im
ländlichen Raum ja nicht in der Stadt
und dort steigen die Netzentgelte und
das sind viele Themen und wir müssen
zusehen dass Stadt und Land zusammen
bleiben und Frau Schwesig das würde ich
gerne aufnehmen sie sagen da hat sich
einiges aufgestaut das sehen wir auch an
den Umfragewerten der Bundesregierung im
Politbarometer gerade am Freitag
sieht man einen massiven
Vertrauensverlust in die Ampel auch wenn
Neuwahlen jetzt momentan nicht
realistisch kann eine Regierung mit so
wenig Rückhalt in der Bevölkerung
einfach so weiter regieren oder braucht
es eine neue Legitimation durch
Neuwahlen nein es braucht keine
Neuwahlen es geht jetzt um die Sache es
geht um die Lösung und
die Menschen wollen dass z.B dieses
Problem jetzt gelöst wird größer als nur
zum Agrardiesel und es geht darum dass
wir eine Perspektive haben wie ist die
weitere wirtschaftliche Entwicklung wie
kriegen wir Energiepreise in den Griff
wie bekommen wir so mehr sozialen
Zusammenhalt hin und beim Klimaschutz
ist ganz wichtig ja die große Mehrheit
sagt wir wollen Klimaschutz aber er muss
eben machbar sein er muss bezahlbar sein
und ich habe ja die
koalitionsverhandlung der Ampel erlebt
und habe da wirklich viel Hoffnung
gehabt dass es uns gelingt
wirtschaftliche soziale und ökologische
Fragen zu verbinden und nicht
gegeneinander zu stellen und der Geist
der damals war mehr diese Dinge
zusammenzuführen und vielleicht nicht so
viel darüber zu streiten der soll wieder
aufleben und ich bin ganz ich glaube die
große Mehrheit der Bürger will einfach
nur dass regiert wird und dass die
Entscheidung gut erklärt werden und dass
vor allem unser Land zusammen bleibt
sagt die Ministerpräsidentin von
melenburg vorp herzlichen Dank für das
Gespräch Frau schwiesig ich danke Ihnen